the wonder of being on this earth
is that there is this possibility to
tell our own story and beyond that to
build stories we can hand on to other
people to empower them to tell their own
stories
and it all goes back to this sense of
dynamism that you're talking about um
and also these emotions that you're
talking about and to unite us and to
unite us in a collective story so that
we can work cooperatively together
towards the same ends right so that we
all come under the same banner in some
sense and that's that shared
intentionality that's that's very
specifically human you don't see that
much manifest itself much in other
animals even the higher apes have a hard
time with it compared to us
absolutely yes and you know what's a big
what's really important about that is
that it's ultimately voluntary
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm pleased to have with me today
dr angus fletcher who
wrote wonderworks
which is a study of the psychology of
stories the psychology of narrative
i'm going to read you dr fletcher's bio
from the back cover
dr angus fletcher is a professor
at ohio state university's project
narrative the world's leading academic
think tank for the study of stories
he has dual degrees in neuroscience and
literature received his phd from yale
taught shakespeare at stanford
and has published two books and dozens
of peer-reviewed academic articles on
the scientific workings of novels poetry
film and theater
his research has been supported by the
national science foundation the mellon
foundation and the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences he's done
story consulting
for projects for sony disney the bbc
amazon pbs and nbc universal
and is the author presenter of the
audible slash great courses gr guide to
screenwriting
so dr fletcher thank you very much for
agreeing to talk to me today and
i'm looking forward to this conversation
greatly so
let's start a bit with this project
narrative at ohio state i hadn't heard
of that previously and so tell me how
you got interested in that and then
maybe how you got interested in this in
the psychology of stories more broadly
well thanks for being uh thanks for
letting me uh be here jordan i'm
thrilled to uh project narrative is
best known as a rogue outpost
of literary studies we do literary
studies completely differently
from everyone else in the modern academy
basically there was a split in the 1920s
uh that started with new criticism and
new criticism went on to develop what is
essentially
uh the modern modern literary studies
and new criticism is based on the same
method that was used in the middle ages
to interpret the bible that's the same
method that's used really across the
academy even though new criticism has
itself fallen out of favor
and in project narrative we take a
different approach and in my case it's a
scientific approach
we're interested in
studying how stories work in the brain
and the particular focus of my research
is
the belief that stories are the most
powerful things that humans have ever
invented they're the most powerful tool
we possess
and the simple reason for that um
is that the human brain is the most
powerful thing on earth
for good or for bad i mean you look
around the extraordinary achievements of
our mind the cultures we have created
the science we've created the technology
we've created the art we have created
but also the fact that uh we have the
power in us to wipe out this planet to
destroy
everything and
when you realize that stories have the
power to
change how our mind works
uh to
troubleshoot it to make it more
resilient to make it more creative to
make it more scientific to do all these
things you realize that
when you couple the power of stories
with the human brain
you
throw open
the doors
to anything so that's sort of my focus
and that's sort of what we do at project
narrative is we study stories how they
work
scientifically what they do
and because of that we're we're um
considered somewhat heretical somewhat
maverick and definitely on the fringes
uh although i should say i dig in my phd
at yale
so
uh all of us are our reputable hand and
well-respected scholars
so are are you on the fringes
in among psychologists or among literary
critics
no not amongst psychologists so i mean
one of the extraordinary things about my
career is that my work is backed by some
of the biggest neuroscientists and
psychologists in the world
um doctors
nurses social workers
big businesses the us army uh special
operations community the air force i
mean there's an enormous amount of
backing from my work among people who
are
pragmatic and empirically based and are
interested in science
but um
the way that literary studies has become
i mean i mean what has happened in
literary studies is because
everyone is using this method which is
really from the middle ages
the same thing is happening in literary
studies now that happened in the middle
ages people read the same book
they come up with conflicting
interpretations of them those
interpretations reflect their ideal
ideologies and then they argue about
them and so we just have these sort of
endless uh combustions
uh that don't go anywhere just like the
protestants and the catholics in the
middle ages and so you know what my work
basically says is what if we just back
out of that and what if we just do the
same thing that science has done and we
focus
on the way that stories can empower us
uh the story the way the stories can
improve our human performance
because that's really why they were
created by our ancestors our ancestors
came to be in a tragic world where they
realized their own frailty and
insufficiency they said how do i cope
with this life
how do i find strength uh in the face of
my own mortality uh how do i lift myself
up when i see so much failure within
myself i see so much frailty in terms of
my capacity for for anger uh for hate um
and also my ability to be damaged my
ability to suffer grief and trauma and
loneliness how do i lift myself up what
tool could help me do that and so the
beginning of that
literature with
early scriptures there's a ton of
technologies as i talk about in my work
that we can actually trace their effects
in the brain
and then going beyond that healing work
into actually making us into our better
selves empowering us with with joy with
creativity with resilience with the
power to lift up others and perhaps most
importantly the power to grow
to not stay still
to take on damage and turn that damage
around into a source of strength and so
what my work does is my work focuses on
how literature does all those things
which all of us know intuitively all of
us have read a book at some time have
read a novel at some time or watched a
movie at some time or read a poem at
some time and felt healed or uplifted or
strengthened
if you have a favorite musician a
favorite artist a favorite rapper you
know you'll listen to their lyrics and
feel the same thing but the question has
always been how how is it doing that and
so my work goes into that but also more
powerfully my voice my work breaks down
the technology of literature so you can
identify the specific nuts and bolts the
specific blueprints that are having
those specific effects and so that's the
work that i do at project narrative so
in in wonder works in this in this book
which i referred to earlier
you
list out what you consider 25 inventions
and they basically constitute the
chapter structure of the book and so you
examine the manner in which stories do
such things as
rally courage or
stoke romance or help control anger or
transcend hurt or excite curiosity i'm
not going to go through all of them but
to
dispense with pessimism and banish
despair and heal from grief and
decide more wisely and so in some sense
it's a listing of existential concerns
and so
you've broken down narrative in this in
these 25 ways in this book to discuss
the major sources of existential concern
that plagued mankind and then
have
put forward the notion that we have
stories that surround each of these
fundamental concerns that help us
understand
verbalize communicate about and maybe
see a pathway through
each of these the in the case of the
terrible emotions each of the terrible
emotions or to foster and develop the
ones that are more positive
i mean that's exactly right and and even
more than that so i mean part of what
stories do is they is they give us a
plot a road map out of some of these
negative emotions into positive emotions
but even more powerfully they can
actually shape our emotions once we
understand how to use them
certain stories can just build optimism
or resilience or courage so to take the
first chapter of the book which is about
courage
homer resilient
this extraordinary work
when you
read the iliad it makes you feel
braver it makes you feel stronger and it
can do that even when it's not talking
about courage even even when it has no
message about courage even when it's
talking about other well how does it do
that well homer he probably didn't
invent this technology uh but we don't
know who who who did it before him so we
give home her credit
homer realized that when he saw soldiers
marching into war
they sang songs
and those songs made them feel braver
why did those songs make them feel
braver well those songs made them feel
part of a larger voice
they felt they were bigger than
themselves and on a deep psychological
level they could feel that strength
because they knew that even if their
individual body died the voice would
carry on
and that's a that's a that's a
scientific power of song we know that to
be the case that when people sing
together in choirs they feel braver they
feel more courageous
and so what homer did is he said well
what if i could give you that power of
singing without you actually singing
what if i could create a technology a
way of writing so that it tricked your
brain into thinking that you were
singing as part of a choir
and that's of course what the iliad does
it makes you believe that you are
listening to the song of a god
sing goddess of the anger that's how it
begins and it uses all these tricks and
techniques which i go through in the
book into making your brain believe
that you are singing as part of this
larger course and so when you simply
read the book it makes you feel braver
and that technique
that idea that you had there that
it that that group singing unites you
with the central voice whose existence
transcends death i mean there's a very
deep religious like idea in there that's
that's implicit right that there is a
voice and there are words that unite and
transcend and that supersede death and
so that's some that's part of that
heroic pattern i suppose that that homer
is referring to that you can step into
as
uh and what would you say an active
agent in in engaging in this literature
just like when you walk into a movie and
you
you embody the heroes or the or the
anti-heroes sometimes that you see on
the screen and experience the emotions
that they experience for better or for
worse as a as i suppose as a form of
practice
that's exactly right and you know one of
the things that is distinct about the
homeric gods is they're large humans
you know homeric gods you know unlike
some sort of an extreme gnostic version
of god as you know as the via negative
or something that is completely
non-human and that we can't access
these homeric gods are essentially
heroes in the sense of just being bigger
versions of us and so they're gripped
with all the same problems that we have
all the same frailties that we have um
jealousy rage insufficiency and so when
you join with them in this bigger voice
just as you would in in a hero in a
movie
you feel that you are
becoming yourself only greater
you don't feel like you're losing
yourself but you're joining this bigger
thing that is yourself that makes you
bigger that makes more powerful and
that's where the spiritual experience
comes from and absolutely one of the one
of the basic primordial experiences of
literature which is so basic i don't
even include it as one of the
technologies in the book i just talk
about it in the introduction is
spiritual experience
we can actually detect you having
deactivation in your parietal lobe as
you have what's known as a
self-transcendent experience in which
you feel the boundaries of yourself and
the world dissolving between yourself
and the world dissolving
and that's associated with increased
life purpose increased generosity and
kindness because you no longer have the
same sense of ego you feel connected to
others and that sense of spiritual i
mean the word literature and the word
scripture are synonyms
they mean that which is writ
and so if there's one fundamental thing
more fundamental even than any of the
technologies i talk about to get from
literature it simply is that sense of
spiritual experience and i do think that
that is the the basic and most powerful
experience that any of us can have in
this world because it makes us not only
stronger and more purposeful in
ourselves but kinder to others and
really that's ethics to be stronger in
yourself and kinder dollars
right to be more effective and more
useful socially broadly
so okay i want to i want to
ask you a couple of things i've done a
lot of thinking about narrative
when i read
i read this book back in the 1980s the
neuropsychology of anxiety by jeffrey
gray and that book had a tremendous
impact in the field of psychology
although it took about 20 years before
people
i suppose incorporated at least some of
what gray
had proposed and he got a lot of his
ideas although i didn't know it at the
time from
norbert weiner weiner i don't know how
to say his name a brilliant a
cybernetician who
worked on establishing what might be the
basis of
of uh intelligent abstraction and so
that it could be mechanized and uh
so i read gray at the same time
and learned about his association with
weiner and cybernetics and
at the same time that i was reading a
lot of uh analytical psychology mostly
by jung and his
his uh students
and i started to understand that the
the basic cybernetic mechanisms that
gray was discussing as characteristic of
cognitive processing
seem to me to be the same thing as the
fundamental elements of the story so let
me run this by you and you tell me what
you think about this okay we'll see
how our thinking is meshing perhaps and
differing
so
i thought that
that there are are basically two types
of stories in in in a functional sense
there's a simple story
and there's a story about how stories
transform
and the story itself is actually the
frame of reference that we use to
perceive the world and act within
so i i don't think we have a
i don't think we think and then we think
in stories as a subset of thinking i
think that
the story is the frame for our thought
and that frame is actually what produces
our motivation and our emotions and so a
lot of this is again influenced by this
cybernetic work that was developed by
graham which his tremendous knowledge of
animal behavior and cognition because he
was an absolute genius i think he cited
two thousand papers in the
uh neuropsychology of anxiety took me
like six months to read that book and
understand it he's really dense so
imagine that
that in the simple story
you mentioned literature as a story as a
map
and i think that's the fundamental issue
so we're always somewhere
that's our starting point and we're
always moving somewhere else because
we're active creatures and so and we
have an image of the destination in mind
and so
we we
we segregate up time and space
into
a functional unit that enab that defines
the geographical and temporal bounds of
our current operations and we specify a
target
and
even when when we're
when our imagination is free floating
partly what we're doing is playing with
different spatial temporal frames of
reference so we might be playing with 10
minutes we might be playing with an hour
we might be playing with a day we might
be playing with two weeks we can we can
expand and contract that more or less it
will
but so the map
the map covers a spatial temporal domain
okay and then
the
the goal
is
specified and then
we feel positive emotion
when we see any indication from the
environment environmental feedback that
our actions are moving us towards the
goal
and we feel
and that's technically positive affect
because it's associated with forward
movement left hemisphere activation
dopaminergically mediated
so we can we can we can conceptualize
the goal abstractly interestingly enough
and we have to do that because we can
play with these spatial temporal frames
of reference
and then
we if we see a pathway to the goal
a clear pathway that we can implement
behaviorally
then that fills us with positive emotion
if we see obstacles in the way
then that induces negative emotion and
stops us and when we stop we'll
play around with the spatiotemporal
framing making it smaller maybe we have
to deal with the next minute or larger
trying to reconceptualize the territory
so that we can continue our movement
forward
okay so that's that's story number one
simple story i was here
i went there um
and here's how i got there and you might
want to listen to that because maybe
you're there and you want to get to the
goal and you need directions
okay the the next story is different
it's it's the transformation of stories
and so it's the typical fall or paradise
fall
paradise rekindled story
so
you have a frame of reference
you're moving towards a goal
something that
isn't modeled within that frame of
reference occurs
it's like an alien invader in some sense
it doesn't make sense from within that
current frame of reference it blows the
frame of reference into pieces
there are you enter a land of in some
sense of narrative fragments that's the
underworld in mythology
you have to sort those narrative
fragments up and rebuild them remap the
territory and then
then you build another story so that's a
meta-story it's a story about how a
story can decompose
collapse into catastrophe and rekindle
itself
and it seemed to me that
there isn't anything more basic to our
abstract thinking than that sort of
nesting inside of stories
first of all i completely agree on the
overall point so i mean i actually have
a book coming out next year on columbia
university press and the title is story
thinking because basically my belief is
that human cognition is largely
narrative um and that actually we
process the world narratively uh in this
exact way and this is actually what
makes our brain function different from
computers and ai um whether or not
computers and humans can do the same
tasks
we do them differently uh computers
think in these kinds of logical
correlational sequences
and humans to your point think in plots
and plans and narratives and goals um
and those plots and plans are then
associated with emotions because the
computer exists in the mathematical
present tense so it cannot have desire
there's nothing missing to a computer
because it's always in the same place
all the time it's always it's always the
equal sign of the mathematical present
tense but we as the humans are able
through plotting and planning to imagine
a future that's distinct from the
present which creates desire or fear or
hope or all these other emotions and so
narrative and emotion just go together
completely in human experience and you
know that's why emotions are both shaped
through narrative but narratives are
also shaped through emotion so you know
um
the kind of simple thing uh is to say
well you know we can use narratives to
influence people's emotions i mean this
is the sort of thing that you know is
somewhat sometimes positive but often a
kind of cheap political trick
right right scare people or manipulate
them into doing things and whatnot but
the real power here is to say first of
all how can i shape my own emotions with
narratives
what emotions in other words i'm not
trying to shape your emotions i'm trying
to shape my own emotions i'm trying to
control my own anger
or increase my own hope how do i do that
by retelling my own stories in my own
head um and then the second factor of
that is how can my emotions come into
play and enable my narratives how can i
develop the emotional resilience to be
more likely to carry on my own story how
can i complete my story even though i
have these obstacles in front of me and
to me the function of literature so
literature is is related to stories but
slightly different in the fact that
literature is really the kind of
experimental zone where you're pushing
the envelope i mean you know literary
writers are are people who are somewhat
dissatisfied to to kind of you know talk
you know to think about how you're
talking about stories breaking they're
dissatisfied with the stories they have
you know they're not working you know
and they say how can i take these
stories and somehow make them new how
can i innovate them how can i go beyond
the stories that i've inherited you know
how can i push that envelope and so
really what i do in the book is say you
know here's 25 examples of how stories
were broken and then put back together
again and how this technology just like
you know any technology that humans have
developed has been expanded and
innovated over time to go beyond that
simple
i just have to get to this goal story
which i agree with you is that i mean
that's a fundamental uh story beginning
end you know the most basic unit you
know beginning end and i find myself in
the middle um but you know the the
wonder of being on this earth
is that there is this possibility to
tell our own story and beyond that to
build stories we can hand on to other
people to empower them to tell their own
stories
and it all goes back to this sense of
dynamism that you're talking about um
and also these emotions that you're
talking about and to unite us and to
unite us in a collective story so that
we can work cooperatively together
towards the same ends right so that we
all come under the same banner in some
sense and that's that shared
intentionality that's that's very
specifically human you don't see that
much manifest itself much in other
animals even the higher apes have a hard
time with it compared to us
absolutely yes and you know what's a big
what's really important about that is
that it's ultimately voluntary because i
mean again if we brainwash people to
have the same story as us you know
that's to me um a biological no-go it's
not particularly effective and it's
unethical but if we find a story that's
so compelling that when we share with
someone else it empowers them and then
they join our story so let's talk about
that compelling issue because that's
something that's really
phenomenally interesting
so
you can get gripped by a story
right and that's sort of extra rational
and what i mean by that because and that
makes sense if it's if the story is the
frame within which rationality takes
place
this this being gripped by a story would
be extra rational and so you can see
that when you walk into a movie theater
and you get engaged maybe even despite
yourself you might be thinking i didn't
want to go to this stupid movie my
girlfriend just dragged me there and
then you know
it's it's it's it's too far-fetched for
me to suspend disbelief as if you
suspend disbelief voluntarily because
you really don't the story grips you and
so
you're in there and you're gripped and
then you know someone taps you on the
shoulder and says you know this isn't
real and you say shut the hell up
because i'm i'm watching the story right
so
so the question then is from a
psychological perspective is
what is that mechanism of grip and what
might its biological roots be and my
sense is
you know if you watch little kids you
watch a three-year-old
a three-year-old will be enthralled by a
three and a half year old or a
four-year-old now they're not enthralled
to the same degree by a
fourteen-year-old
i mean
and the reason for that you didn't
criticize this okay because i want your
perspective on it
so
vygotsky talked about the zone of
proximal development
and
vygotsky pointed out that
i believe it was vygotsky but it's been
established by other psychologists in
any case that
parents
use
language
automatically in the presence of
children who are developing their
linguistic skills that is somewhat more
complex than the child can currently
understand
so they communicate with them but at the
same time they're communicating with
them they're teaching them how to
communicate better by stretching their
limits so that's like that stretch you
talk about in in wonder works okay so
i'm going somewhere with this so now you
got your three-year-old and your
three-year-old is enthralled by a
four-year-old and the reason that
they're enthralled is because the
four-year-old is a stretch for them but
almost within their grip
so what the what the enthralment does i
don't know if that's a word
being enthralled is a manifestation of
the instinct that specifies the zone of
proximal development and facilitates
imitation
so we're unbelievably imitative right
and what we're moving back and forth are
units of behavior or units of perception
and when we find one that is that that
our intuition senses is in the zone of
proximal development then we're gripped
despite ourself by the power of the
story
and that's and the biological basis of
that i believe is
the the instinct for mimicry
and that's what's operating in
literature as well it's abs it's it's
abstract mimicry
any of that seem
implausible well so first of all to your
first point um i completely agree that
we
seek out growth spaces i would use the
term growth uh in other words the sense
that we're always looking for that
threshold where we can pull ourselves
forward and become more actualized
um and and enter that space where um
you know we become
uh you know more of the self we can be
and want to be so and absolutely that
again goes down to plot i mean plot is
always about the next step the reason
that plot and narrative are so powerful
is again unlike logic which is eternal
plot is always about the next step where
are you going
and where are you growing and so plot
naturally plugs into that because i mean
the first thing that happens to us even
when we watch a bad movie is we want to
know where is this going
i mean if you watch a movie for even
just 30 seconds that's usually your
first where are these characters going
what's happening here you know this
isn't going anywhere
right right and then i gotta walk out of
it you know so just but then what makes
the movie emotionally gripping to your
point is the sense that's taking me
somewhere where i want to go or in other
words where my psychology wants to grow
it's pulling me and growing me and
developing me so i could agree with all
that completely 100
um what i think is interesting is you
know again this is sort of the work that
we do is that
different people we just notice are
drawn in by different aspects of stories
um and different stories draw people in
differently so this all goes back to
biology so i'll just give you a few
quick top lines and you tell me if you
buy any of this or you want me to go
deeper so we just know the thing the
human brain is most interested in is
other people the human brain is just
most interested in other people um and
that's because other people
inevitably are both
our greatest opportunities in life and
our greatest obstacles
uh you know in other people we see our
friends our mates you know our potential
partners our children whatever our
legacies but we also see our adversaries
our critics and so humans just notice
other humans very very quickly and
prioritize them incredibly quickly and
that's why characters are so important
stories um we identify characters um and
we develop these relationships with
those characters which can be imitative
in a heroic story but we have other
relationships with characters too we can
have crushes on characters um you know
we can feel protective of characters
it's also relationships you can have so
the first thing that will often get us
to grip is just the characters in the
story because they're a human
the second thing that humans notice
immediately is the world i mean the
human brain evolved in this incredibly
dynamic landscape we're constantly
having to shift uh where we're living we
constantly move into new terrains
because they have to be brave and so we
have this huge ability to immediately
sense what is this
new environment how is it working what
are the different rules that operate
here and we get this in modern society
all the time whenever you enter into you
know a different person's home or a
different business space or whatever you
immediately sense okay the rules of
operation here a little bit different
and you pick them up and you modulate
your own behavior and
and in films this is the most obvious
effect of like a sci-fi world or a
fantasy world you immediately feel like
okay here's the space i'm going into
where i can pull out parts of myself and
explore them but you can also feel that
in a very realistic story if you just
feel that that human environment is
somehow different from your own and the
possibilities for human action in that
space and that's very exciting and
empowering for us as well um so that's
the second major thing and the third
thing is the story itself
if the story itself is taking you on a
journey that you recognize on some level
as a journey
you could take and might want to take
but haven't taken yet then you say to
yourself this is a growth space for me
because by going on this journey by
continuing this plot i can go to places
and most importantly not just external
places but internal places i can find
out who i become
when i go on this journey which i
haven't gone on before okay let me ask
you let me ask you a question yeah okay
let me ask you a question about that
because that's kind of a mystery eh so
how is it
so you have the three-year-old who's
watching the three and a half year old
and the three-year-old figures out that
or is gripped by the three and a half
year old because
he or she can almost do that
and then you see the same thing in
adults you're talking about this growth
opportunity how the hell do you think we
conceptualize what we could be so that
we can see that instinctively when we
don't know what we could be because we
aren't that yet you know what i mean is
we got some conception of what
constitutes the horizon even though
we're not there and and
so
well i do well first of all i don't want
to pretend to have the final answer to
this and you know one of the reasons i
wrote the book and one of the reasons i
think story is so wonderful is we just
need to do more research on it and i
would love anyone out there just to
dedicate their lives to delve more to
these mysteries i just want to put that
out there that you know i mean this is a
huge mystery and it might be the most
important mystery but one of the things
i can say
is that
one of the things we know about the
origins of story in the human brain is
it goes below consciousness
a lot of what goes through our
consciousness um it's just simply tiny
parts of the story machinery of our deep
brain and our that's one of the reasons
why
opportunities for action ideas just seem
to just pop fully formed into our
consciousness
if you work as a writer ever i mean i've
done a ton of work in hollywood um all
of a sudden these ideas just pop in your
head where do they come from well
there's a huge amount of unconscious
machinery in there and another way of
saying that is there's this huge
processing system this operating system
that's constantly hypothesizing like a
little scientist here's what could
happen here's what could happen here's
what could happen and when all of a
sudden your conscious brain gets an
opportunity with what you're with one of
the possibilities your unconscious brain
has click it says let's go
um
and the main point here is that the
human brain the flip side of anxiety is
creativity they're both about restless
energy they're both about restless
imagining they're both
about restlessly thinking what could be
and anxiety manifests itself as as the
the nervous side of that the fearful
side of that you know the more negative
affect side of that but creativity
manifested as the more hopeful side of
that and our brain evolved
to be constantly trying to grow because
otherwise it was dead
i mean in the kind of primordial culture
which would evolve you could not sit
still
you would get eaten
and so the whole pressure on you
biologically was
can you get to that next step we don't
know what it is yet and it can't be
preordained because life around you is
evolving
so and humans around you are evolving
and so to a certain extent there has to
be this open-endedness to the process
where you're both piggybacking on other
people but
also leaping in a direction that they
might not go okay so here so i've got
i've got some comments about that the
unconscious aspect of that so
i was imagining away while you were
talking and and and thinking about the
structure of that unconscious and so
um
this is part of the reasons why dreams
are
pre-cognitive in some sense this is how
i think it works
so imagine that
we're watching people act all the time
all the time in small groups and large
groups as individuals in fiction
all the time and then
so we have this fast knowledge of
of
embodied action
now that's not
propositionalized it's imagistic
it's like the movie that runs in your
head it's like a dream
we can't propositionalize all that
that's partly what a great storyteller
does is take a great set of images that
reflect a compelling pattern of behavior
and turn it into
verbalized propositions
and that
that
insight you described so imagine
you have these images of behavior and in
those images there are patterns
but we don't know what the patterns are
because they're extremely sophisticated
and we're not intelligent enough to
fully understand them which is only to
say that human behavior at the
individual and the social level
supersedes our um
are are
explicit grasp
no one would dispute that
that's why you have to learn about
yourself which is kind of a strange
thing right you're you but you don't
know who you are and so
we have these
patterns of behavior
at hand and then we abstract out images
of those patterns of behavior and that's
at least in part the source of dreams
it's the abstract representation of the
patterns
not of the actual behaviors themselves
but of the commonalities or something
like that the commonalities between
behavior so imagine this you talked
about the greek gods as being super
humans
okay so
um
there's patterns of behavior that strike
us as admirable
those are in our zone of proximal
development otherwise we don't
understand them
we collect
we our brain and maybe this is a right
hemisphere function our brain makes
associations between these patterns of
admirable behavior based on their
emotional commonality
then it abstracts out a pattern that
constitutes that set of admirable
behaviors okay that's a super stimulus
that's a hero or perhaps someone who's
successful at romance
so and it's the same thing in some sense
that i'll go back to childhood
i was struck when my children were young
about their fantasy play i was very very
interested in fantasy play as a
psychological phenomenon
now one of the things that's very
interesting about watching children
pretend play
is that
we tend to say that what they're doing
is imitating so say they're playing
father when they play house
but they're not actually imitating
because they never do exactly what they
saw their father do what they do is they
watch their father across multiple
manifestations of father behavior and
they combine that with fathers in books
and fathers in movies and
and they're pulling out a pattern of the
father and that's made out of all these
representations of these behavioral
patterns and then the fantasy is trying
to represent that abstractly in images
to draw out the central spirit
and this spirit is the thing that's
imitated and that's what drives the
fantasy play and i also think i'll jump
one more place here that's the source of
the abstraction of religious conceptions
right imagine that you ex extract out
the father as such
it's not characteristic of any one human
being
it's that ideal spirit that transcends
the individual that's immortal in some
sense because it manifests itself in
body after body throughout time
see jung talked about this
space where these transcendent spirits
existed this is something almost no one
knows about his work
he called that the pleroma
and the pluroma was the space that
abstracted figures of imagination exist
above temporality and death
it's a very it's a very weird way of
thinking about it right you can imagine
there's this space that's composed of
the collective imagination
and in that collective imagination there
are beings
and those beings
outlast all of us
now
i'm not making a case that though that
place is material the same way that we
think of materiality but it's a space
that's composed of
it's very difficult all the all the
human nervous systems are constituent
elements of that space and those
characters inhabit that it doesn't
matter if one person dies
the spirit continues you can think about
the spirit of evil that way
and you can think about our attempts to
represent it here's another interesting
thought you know
my my brother-in-law is a computer chip
designer
he's one of the best computer chip
designers in the world
and i've had very interesting
conversations with him about
computation and artificial intelligence
you know interestingly enough and this
is to your point about the importance of
stories
much of what drives the demand for
higher and higher and computational
resources is the
economic viability of producing
artificial realities for fantasy
simulation to play out
scenarios like the eternal battle
between good and evil
you know those movies the marvel movies
for example the superhero movies cost
hundreds of millions of dollars they're
unbelievably technologically
sophisticated they gather huge audiences
and so and that's part of that rep part
of the representation of that pluroma so
to speak so sorry that's a lot of ideas
to throw out at once
no well so um to start with the um
so to start with the artificial
intelligence component i should i should
say that i'm i'm working with eric
larson on on a project for darpa on
artificial intelligence that's also
involving certain elements of the
of the of the military um and um it's
important that
the human brain
has
computational powers which is also more
than a computer um and computers
abstract everything and that's the power
of a computer and that's the power of
logic is to
think of everything in terms of symbols
um but humans have this interesting
interplay between the two because there
needs to be this productive tension at
least in biological life between the
abstract and the particular
if you get too far into the abstract
then you end up in
well you know a world in which
everything is identical on some level or
this sort of identity is there and we
should all be acting the same
and that to me is is essentially the
idea of marxism or communism the idea
that there are these ultimate
you know we can abstract truth out of
enough data i mean ai leads us towards a
world in which there's no volition no
choice no individuality because the
answers become clear through
abstractions of enough data you know and
this is sort of marxist view of science
my view of science is that
life is different from that because our
world
is constantly changing
and so we need to both be able to
abstract and to particularize and that
the abstraction process is incredibly
helpful for us at finding these patterns
that you're talking about these kind of
deeper action scripts deeper characters
but then we have the challenge of
applying it to our own life and then
finding out how we can tell it into our
own story
and so a computer is always going to
exist on the level of the universal
human
i mean computers are always going to try
to go to that point where it can take
all of humanity and find the the kind of
essential unity in
our psyche and as humans we resist that
because we say actually we are different
and that difference is meaningful um and
you know and life also verifies that i
mean the reason that i'm opposed to
communism and marxism is not on
ideological grounds it's on practical
grounds they didn't work and i for the
same reason think that ai doesn't work
okay let let me throw so when i was
thinking about computation i was
thinking more about the fact that the
that the economic demand that drives the
necessity for
more and more potent computational power
is because people want us to render
fictional universes with more and more
sophistication and that's very
interesting that that's what's driving
that immense technological
transformation and then this idea of the
the absolute and the particular
so
i think that that's been a that that is
a fundamental problem and one of the
interesting
that's a story that i don't know how to
exactly frame this properly
that problem
is addressed
in
christian religious doctrine
and
and so let me tell tell me what you
think about this idea in in light of
what you just said
so
we talked already about the set of all
admirable behaviors
and then we could think about the set of
all behaviors that are the opposite of
that
and in some sense that's good and evil
and and as as embodied
like not as abstract ideas the
abstractions there but as embodiment so
you know you'll see you go to a party
and someone will do something they'll
they'll do something disgusting and
you're turned off by that it's like so
that goes into the
collection of
vile actions
and
societies generate characters of vile
action
so
and those are abstracted they can be
abstracted ultimately so in christianity
they're abstracted up into christ and
satan for example and so those are those
are abstractions that haven't completely
lost their particularization because
they're still embodied
okay so but christianity interestingly
enough takes that idea one step further
and this is quite fascinating i think is
because people so there's this there's
this idea that's extraordinarily
abstract
of christ as the hero of heroes and i'm
speaking technically here from a
literary perspective so if you
amalgamated all the heroes across 10 000
years and abstracted out the central
figure this is a jungian notion in some
sense for all intents and purposes that
would be that's the ideal man and if you
encapsulate that within the confines of
western civilization let's say you come
up with the figure of christ it has
nothing to do with the religious
conception in some sense it's purely
speaking psychologically
but then there's the problem of the
abstraction it's too abstract and so the
way christianity solved that in this
weird narrative way is to make this
abstraction
exist in a particular time and place
right two thousand years ago why two
thousand years ago why a carpenter why
in this little god forsaken town that no
one even wanted to visit and the answer
is because the absolute has to meet the
particular
that's the psychological answer and it i
believe it's it's it's an answer that
because obviously christianity is a
narrative whatever else it might be it's
the central narrative of western culture
for better for worse and so
it and then you could you can see this
abstraction particularity issue play out
really interesting too in in the the
difference in similarity between
nietzsche and dostoevsky
because nietzsche abstracted out all
these philosophical principles
and dostoyevsky did extracted out almost
exactly the same principles but they
were all embodied in characters and it's
so interesting to read them in
conjunction
because
dostoevsky's
act out nietzsche's philosophy and
they're more accessible in some sense
and they're they're also broader and
more significant even though they're not
as propositionalized
so
there's untold wisdom in shakespeare
right we haven't particularized all that
we haven't propositionalized all of it
so
yeah okay so that's the absolute in the
particular so yes so so you're going
about christianity i mean i mean
i i take your reading of christianity to
be for example compatible with star wars
um in the sense that luke skywalker is a
very quirky
odd guy you know in the middle of this
random place of course
you know i mean just as weird and odd as
a carpenter in galloway right you know
and yet he is the embodiment of this
kind of eternal spiritual thing you know
and that's and that's and that's where
you get that that kind of melding
together
right in star wars we should just look
at it historically star wars
george lucas
joseph campbell carl jung because all of
campbell's thinking was was union
thinking all of it and the hero with a
thousand faces is a great book
especially as an introduction to that
kind of literature
but yes star wars is christianity for
atheist nerds
yes yes fundamentally yeah and you can't
get rid of that there's no getting rid
of that right if you throw it out
in one direction it comes back in
another and that's something we should
talk about too
well it's a very powerful story yeah no
absolutely the one thing i would want to
say though is that
our
we are most happy when we do not
perceive ourselves as inheriting an
archetypal story from somebody else
if i were to say to you you know um
here's the archetypal story you're going
to end up back there uh at you know that
would be disinteresting to us
emotionally you know we want to tell our
own stories we want to be particular in
ourselves i would also say that
even though human psychology has
remained relatively constant for at
least 300 thousand years and parts of it
for over a million um our world is
changed and has changed and there are
real differences between the way the
world works now the kinds of actions and
behaviors that are going to function now
than there was even 500 years ago um and
so there is this need for flexibility in
narrative so even as what you're talking
about i think jordan is this fundamental
spiritual component of narrative the way
in which narrative can connect us with
the eternal a sense of things bigger
than ourselves and that transcendent
sense of purpose is what lifts us but
narrative also has this flexibility
outside the spiritual in the material
world to say okay how do i navigate this
challenge i'm not going to navigate this
challenge as luke skywalker or christ
because luke skywalker christ didn't
encounter it okay i don't i don't think
it's okay i don't think it's abstracted
outside of the spiritual i think this
relates to the issue of the relationship
between the conscious propositions and
the unconscious under structure so
i think that we think in stories we
frame the world in stories we see in
stories and this is partly why for
example our eyes are adapted
with the whites of our eyes so that
other people can see our eyes
it's really important for us to see
other people's eyes because we can see
where they're pointing their eyes and if
we can see where they're pointing their
eyes we can see what they're interested
in we can see what they value and we can
instantly infer their motivation and
that makes them predictable
and so so and it's so important that
every all of our ancestors whose eyes
weren't that visible either didn't mate
or got killed
it's really important okay so
so we have now this shared narrative so
imagine this is part this perhaps
relates to the particular the absolute
as you specify the narrative for small
scale actions and those would be
particularized
the the connection with the absolute the
larger absolute in some sense falls away
but it's nested
so you could say
if you're an integrated person it's
nested it's so like
right now you're talking to you're
listening to me and sometimes you're
talking to me okay so and the story
there is well we want to have an
engaging conversation and and why well
there's a bigger story outside of that
because we want to further our knowledge
about narrative and we want to share
that with other people
and then there's a story outside of that
which is well why well because we're
both
we're both educators and public
communicators well why bother with that
well because we think education
rationality and narrative are important
for the proper functioning of human
beings well why is that relevant because
we care about the emotional
uh
experience of people and we want to
further their growth because we want
things to be better and what's outside
of that well the idea that
well it's something like the idea that
truthful
and engaged exploration
is of is a high value and then outside
of that well at some point you get to
the ultimate abstraction right which is
the ultimate good and if you're an
integrated person the particular of your
action is associated with that broad
scale abstraction but you don't have to
refer to it in the moment and thank god
for that
it because it would be overwhelming
it would be overwhelming i th here's
something i'll throw just sort of
sideways i think what happens when
people take psychedelic substances that
blow apart their
latent inhibition
is that they start to become cognizant
of those underlying nested structures
like they they start to invade the
current reality and that's what makes it
saturated with meaning and pregnant with
meaning it also sometimes produces that
catastrophically terrible experience
because
if that nesting is fragmented
so maybe there's part of you that's
motivated by bitterness and despair and
jealousy
there's a war at the broader narrative
levels and you're a disintegrated
character
and that's extraordinarily stressful
physiologically partly because you can't
act out the contradictions
you know without running into trouble so
see part of what you're doing in
psychotherapy all the time
and this is like an integration of
cognitive behavioral and analytic
psychology is
you're trying to hammer the person's
narrative into
a single non-contradictory functional
unit at all levels of
apprehension simultaneously
the stories can help with that so yeah
no absolutely so there's actually a
chapter in the book where i talk about
how literature can give you the
positives of psychedelics without the
negatives and there's a lot of evidence
that literature particularly certain
types of poetry can deeply stimulate the
visual cortex and create these feelings
of awe and pop that sort of allow you to
open your mind and start to put together
some of the different narratives
different stories you have and yeah so
is that more effective is that more
effective when the lyrics are set to
music
yes
so is it is that being demonstrated
neurologically do you know
well i don't know i don't know about um
i don't know a specific test that has
set the the poems that i've talked about
uh to music but yes absolutely music has
the same
can have the same convergent function
absolutely yeah
um
and as far as the therapeutics go i mean
i mean a lot of the work that i do i
mean i do a lot of work with veterans a
lot of work with trauma survivors
there's no question i mean the origins
of greek tragedy
are therapeutic
it was written
largely i mean initially by veterans uh
performed largely for veterans in
ancient athens and when you take out the
story components of oedipus and you use
them in modern military settings they
continue to have these cathartic effects
because they continue to allow soldiers
to access these deep and dangerous
um parts of themselves and and of the
world i mean the thing that happens in
war is you get tragic knowledge
tragic knowledge of the world and of
yourself
sometimes sometimes malevolent knowledge
which is even worse like the people i've
seen who were traumatized
were not so much traumatized by tragedy
as they were traumatized by malevolence
because that's the voluntary imposition
of tragedy and there's something about
and so one of the things you see with
soldiers is that often when they get
traumatized it's not because something
terrible happened to them it's because
they watched themselves do something so
terrible they can't imagine being human
and having done that
and so
so one of the things you jung pointed
out for example when he was dealing with
people who were extraordinarily
traumatized was that
helping people understand the battle
between good and evil let's say so
that's that's a narrative at the highest
level of abstraction
is to understand that
because imagine what would happen if you
in some sense had to take personal
responsibility for your own malevolence
and and you got a glimpse of that right
a glimpse of that murderous malevolence
that you're capable of and you have
nothing no place to put it well if you
can put it in a universal narrative you
can say well these powerful forces of
good and evil are always operating
beneath the surface and and that's been
the case for the entire corpus of human
history and god only knows what it means
in the final analysis but it's possible
for an individual to be caught up in
that and that's not an excuse right but
you man if you've done something
terrible you and you need to recover you
need a story to put that in because
otherwise it just hangs it's like the
sword of damocles over your head all the
time who the hell am i who i'm capable
of that sort of thing who the hell am i
and you can't live without an answer to
that question
no and i think also i will say to move
the the conversation not just veterans i
think all of us do things in our lives
that we're ashamed of um and that we
wonder where that comes from and then we
have to square with our with our own
experience
yes but definitely
i mean one thing i'll say is at the
bottom of my world view is darwin not
jung so i i myself don't
subscribe i'm an agnostic i don't
subscribe to strict good and evil i mean
i subscribe to pain
and
and joy or something like that um and so
a lot of what i do that's at the
propositional level but you still admire
star wars
but but so a lot of what i think um
a lot of trauma processing
is actually subconscious i mean you know
your conscious brain it helps to have a
narrative and a story you know and and
to that's empowering to say this is my
life i am to some extent engaging in
authoring it and there's no question
that the more you can perceive
yourselves off in your own life but i
mean also a lot of it is simply just in
the memorial circuits of our brain the
amygdala and a lot of it um just is
crashing around in there and causing
flashbacks and other forms of of
symptoms because it hasn't been
processed okay so let's talk about that
hasn't been processed
okay so now
you're driving somewhere that
ah i'll give you an example
i was at the orpheum theater in in la i
think it was the orpheum downtown and i
hadn't been in downtown l.a i was with
my wife and we went for a walk i think
we camped in some trailer outside the
orpheum when i was on this tour i camped
with my wife in these mobile homes
outside theaters in downtowns of cities
which was really weird but anyways we
went for a walk in la and
we walked about two blocks and all of a
sudden we were we were somewhere where
we absolutely shouldn't have been it was
not a good neighborhood it was a
seriously seriously bad neighborhood and
so
we didn't have a map for that
neighborhood
we didn't know how to act in that
neighborhood and so
any territory that
you cannot perceive
through the overlaid projection of a
narrative map
is traumatizing
and so
and so those fragments that re-emerge
those are
those are territories that have not been
mapped with a narrative and the reason
that they re-emerge is because the
anxiety systems so the amygdala in
concert with the hippocampus and and
this is probably a right hemisphere
function
it collects
unmapped territory representations
right and then it amalgamates them and
it attempts to find commonalities
between them that's part of the process
of unconscious mapping that leads to the
ability to produce a narrative and
that's partly what dreams do
so you can see
if you deal with people who are
traumatized and you do dream analysis
you can see the dreams producing
fragmentary representations of the
of the of the unmapped territory that
they've wandered into
and part of what dream analysis can do
is further that process by making the
new mapping explicit
so so i mean a big part so first of all
the fact that that experience happened
to you in los angeles is not surprising
to me as someone who spent a lot of time
in los angeles i mean the city itself
literally tries to be anarchic i think
actually for the reason that you're
talking about because it sees that as
generative narrative i mean there's
almost this way in which the city itself
has emerged to
um
be unmapped spaces or spaces in
collision with each other uh as a way of
generating this sense of constant
storytelling constant story thinking um
constant narration i mean other cities
are not as fertile in that regard if you
look at shakespearean england same thing
i mean it was a very chaotic city uh it
was not at all like uh napoleon's paris
it was not laid out in a kind of
geometric shape and that's why i mean i
think it enabled um and created an
audience for shakespearean plays which
at their root are about these collisions
are about stories coming together
breaking apart i mean lear seems to me
the sort of epicenter of that kind of
narrative experience where you have
everyone in the story having their mind
break down but in a different way
because they're in different unmapped
spaces or different
moments of collision and then at the end
of the play the play basically turns to
you and says are you going to be able to
make coherence of this
you know and that is both the terror but
of the opportunity of lear and that's
why lear inspired um
steve jobs i mean that's why leader
inspired van gogh i mean it's a play
that if you put your mind into it it
will blow your mind apart but if you can
put your mind back together again you
will have something that changes your
reality and possibly everyone else's
reality too
so i'm one of the things i i've always
been struck by in that academic
psychological community is
you mentioned that at the bottom of your
supposition network says darwin and not
jung
i mean
there is a tremendous resistance among
academic psychologists
to take a look at analytical psychology
and it's a huge mistake it's a huge
mistake especially for people who are
interested in narrative
and i i you know it's a hill i've been
trying to climb for a very long time
trying to convince people of this
because
jung has a bad name as a mystic let's
say which is um
unwarranted accusation given what he was
attempting to analyze if you're
interested in story i mean the hero with
a thousand faces
there's three versions of that book
there's the hero with a thousand faces
there's
the origins and history of consciousness
by eric neumann
and there's
psychological transformations i hope
i've got that right it's jung's book
and they're all the same book they're
just written by different people
the origins and history of consciousness
was written by eric neumann and he was
jung's most outstanding student jung
wrote the prologue to that and said that
was the book that he wished he would
have written when he wrote
is it psychological transformations i
hope i've got that right
the hero with a thousand phases is a
narrative analysis of these super
stimulus
super stimuli that you described in
wonder works
but all of that's taken from this
underlying investigation that was
conducted by jung and it's summarized
best in eric neumann's book the origins
and history of consciousness and
that book isn't widely known among
academics and it's a big mistake now i
talked to camille pagley about this
and paglia's more in the field of the
literary criticism that
that's that's that you're
differentiating yourself from
but she told me and this was with no
prompting from me
that
the cultural split that we see now is
predicated in part upon literary critics
following the guidelines of foucault and
dereda
paglia believed it's palya actually
believed that
we should have turned to the origins and
history of consciousness by eric neumann
because he got the story of narrative
right
and i believe that that's true if you're
looking for a single book that takes you
into this vast corpus of analytical
thought about the symbolism of
literature that is by far the most valid
entry point
and it's really something for someone
like jung to say this is the book that i
tried my whole life to write but
couldn't
well so
i will be honest again i mean i like
jung a lot i admire him as a thinker and
i think that he is himself a magician
with story um i am however not of the
view that um
there is one master story out there in
that kind of jungian way
i mean the the the and you can feel free
and i know you will to demolish this but
so let me just start with the darwinian
view of life i mean in darwinian view of
life um to have a jungian view you'd
have to have this idea that over time
there evolved the story um if you're
darwinian that just worked all the time
and it kind of got embedded in our brain
and we could go back to it over and over
again
on the view that i hold life because
it's unstable and changing requires us
to adapt
and therefore narrative is flexible
narrative allows us to adapt narrative
is another word for plot is another word
for plan we can be flexible we can shift
that's not to say that certain stories
don't have deep
emotional and spiritual
power over our brain those stories do
but that's one category of stories i
mean the idea of the book is to say um
there's a ton of stuff that stories can
do for our brain
let's go to the stories let's see what
makes each story different from every
other story as opposed to archetypal i
mean let's let's go into the
particularity so again i'm not saying
this is the only approach i'm just
saying that my approach is basically the
opposite of ewings so maybe we're yin
and yay no let's so no that's a that's a
that's a perfectly reasonable um um
objection and in some sense and i think
it's very tightly associated with this
discussion that we engaged in a little
bit about the particular versus the
absolute and so
you know your objection is
and and it's
mercia eleadah
great historian of religion
great storyteller
he talked about deus abscondus
so we have this idea from nietzsche
let's say of the death of god
now iliada
and he isn't saying this in reference to
nietzsche
said that one of the problems that
religious systems across time faced
was
deus abscondus the disappearing god and
his proposition was
as you move towards a universal absolute
the absolute gets so departicularized
that no one knows how to embody it and
it loses all emotional connection the
catholics solve this problem to some
degree with the saints
right because they're quasi deities in
some sense that that and and they're
very diverse in their behaviors but this
deus abscondus problem according to
iliada has plagued humanity forever we
we abstract out these universal ideals
but they become so abstract that they no
longer have any grip right they lose
their narrative grip
and so
your your objection
and forgive me if i've got this wrong is
that you have to be careful about
stressing the absolute to too great a
degree because you missed the advantages
of the particular but we could say i
think the way to solve that is to go
back to the idea of of this nesting of
stories
right is that
you want to rely on the particular
because it provides you with specific
instructions about how to act here and
now but when it fails you refer to a
level below that that's more abstract to
drop a new set of particulars and so the
unions are investigating the base which
it would be now see because i would say
an objection to your objection is
no we have this problem of particularity
because we have our individual
personalities and there are particular
problems we have to solve but we have to
unify our behavior under some set of
abstractions because otherwise we can't
exist socially and cooperatively right
without a standard set of values and
maurice and we're disintegrated
internally
so we need to solve the problem of
particularity and universality
simultaneously
and so
i i wouldn't throw out the universality
end of it because it isn't in
contradiction to that it's the nesting
solves that problem well look i agree so
first of all um anyone who knows me will
tell will tell you that yes i am the
most rigorously unified person in my own
behaviors and it's possible that part of
my own obsession with particularity
comes from the fact that i am unified
already and so i'm drawn in a way to
find the specific um but i agree with
that completely i mean i think that
there needs to be a balance of the two
it's just that my own career my own
expertise is in the specific and i have
gotten a huge amount of grip in that
area because no one has really looked
for that before and a big part of my
research is to say what's actually
different not just about shakespeare and
homer but what's different about hamlet
and lear what's different about hamlet
and henry v what different story
mechanisms are in them if we push those
forward can we actually track different
mental effects of those yes we can and
so that's to your point that's not at
all to abnegate the general nor to say
that the future of humanity lies in some
sort of diaspora condition in which
we're all just reading single text but
it is to say that you know there's
clearly more for us to learn and the
danger of generalities and abstractions
is always the belief that somehow we
know more than we do because we will say
oh you know i've seen that before or or
i know that already you know um and you
know one of the problems i think with
hollywood nowadays is that the impact of
star wars was which is a tremendous
movie i mean the original star wars i
love but the problem is everyone said oh
that solved the problem of movies we're
just going to keep telling that same
movie over and over and over and over
and over again
and that's not enough that's not enough
i mean you don't want to make this
mistake of having a great breakthrough
and then thinking that's all there is
and so the purpose of the book is
basically 25 things that are incredibly
focused but each of them has this effect
you know i mean i talk about for example
how socrates develops this technology
for allowing you to float above hertz um
or i talk about how hamlet has a
technology for helping you grieve or how
the godfather makes you less lonely or
maybe even more importantly how their
technologies can make you more creative
more imaginative um more emotionally
resilient i mean that's the work that
i'm doing now with the military and the
special operations community um right so
you're opening up multiple areas of of
research by engaging in that analysis of
particularity right how can stories make
us more courageous how can they make us
more satisfied lovers how can they make
us happier yeah so that
particularization is very good because
you need very very specific hypothesis
to pursue research
so and that's exactly right and that's a
difference between say philosophy and
empirical science i mean in philosophy
you want that unity um and you want to
you want you know you want that kind of
logical coherence um in empirical
science you want to say what is the most
specific thing that i can test that i
can falsify um and this is the reason
honestly why i am unpopular with
literary critics
as you should know there's many ways to
be unpopular with contemporary literary
critics i think you and i have yes i've
embodied some of them yes you and i have
discovered different ways of being
considered heretics um but my particular
way is to say literature can be
incredibly useful
literature can build emotional
and intellectual resilience and the fact
that this has been uptaken um so you
know for example uh at uh the army's um
command and general staff college uh
there are faculty there um uh such as um
uh kenneth long and um richard mcconnell
who uh have adopted
this literature work and have put it
into the curriculum where it's now
training hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of majors who will go on to
become colonels who become generals tell
me more about that
i'd like to know that i'd like to know
the particularities of that so
first of all how did how did they become
convinced that this was useful because
that sounds like something very very
difficult to manage and then how is that
actually taught day to day in some
practical manner
yeah so this is the extraordinary
breakthrough of my career and the sort
of surreal reality break moment that i
had in a miniature of what you've had
you know because you've obviously
ascended to kind of global celebrity and
i've ascended to sort of a minor
celebrity that's probably a good place
to stay i would say
i'm gonna do my best my family certainly
likes it better this way but yeah so
basically so you know after i published
the book i got a call from uh the
university of chicago's business school
actually a professor there greg bunch
who was like have you ever thought of
applying this to business folk and if
you were to say that to your average
literary critic they would immediately
just hang up the phones they'd say oh
that's disgusting you know i don't want
to have anything to do with practical
applications
business faculties right because god you
know they're not trustworthy yeah well i
mean because honestly um
yeah i mean
modern literature has become gripped
with a culture of moralism essentially
this idea that there is right and wrong
and we know it's right and wrong and our
job is to judge people when they when
they shift outside yeah we're going to
go back to that i want you okay
we want to go back let's talk all right
we'll come back to that yeah because i
have a very different view of things
but anyway so you know i i said i said
yes i said i'd be very happy to work
with with business students and we
started applying this and we have since
applied it to numerous fortune 50
companies and c-suites and and greg
bunch who's a wonderful teacher will
charge you forty five thousand dollars a
day um for operationalizing the stuff in
the book uh and um at some point he said
to me angus he said um i have a friend
in the army would you like to talk to
him and so i said absolutely i'd be
happy to talk with someone in the army
um and so we ended up talking no wonder
you're a heretic that's well that's
exactly right
and i just want to say i mean i think um
if you if you want to be inspired
talk to somebody in the army talk to
somebody or something i mean i i talked
uh yeah and if you if you want to be
safe in your bloody university you
should thank god that you're surrounded
by a ring of soldiers
who you could look down on for their
immorality while they protect you yeah
and who have the courage of
self-sacrifice who are willing to die
for you i mean this is the thing i just
say is is is what is that i mean that is
is the ultimate heroism to give up your
be willing to give up your life for
somebody else and they make no money
i mean this is the other shocking thing
you go through the army everyone always
says with the you know the military
takes all this money and so and so forth
and it's certainly true that there are a
small number of incredibly expensive
machines that the military has but the
actual personnel in the army and in the
military make almost nothing and and you
know their compensation pay for being
under fire is something like a couple
hundred extra dollars a month i mean
think about that would you take a couple
hundred bucks a month for someone to
shoot at you it's real courage real
heroism uh i work a lot with the nurse
corps the nurse corps is so beyond what
i could even describe i mean i met a
nurse the other day her job is to fly in
these helicopters uh to frontline
casualties jump out of the helicopters
at basically 200 feet and do triage on
these wounded individuals many of whom
are civilians and then bring them back
so their lives can be saved and what's
even more exceptional about that to me
as i discovered she's afraid of flying
she can't get on a plane but she has
that much courage that she gets on these
helicopters and does this thing and
that's me and just everyone i've met in
the military has just had that courage
that self-sacrifice so anyway i got a
call and they say to me and this is
another thing that's typical of the
military is they're always examining
themselves
how many people can you say in your
ordinary life go around examining
themselves in a critical manner and then
say how do i improve myself and this is
just a constant process in the army so i
get this call and they say to me you
know angus we have this concern in the
army we just think we're just not
creative enough
we just feel like you know i mean it you
know we we do these things and then they
work and then we just kind of replicate
them but how do we become more adaptive
how can we go into these situations and
i said well look another word for being
adaptive is to be emotionally and
intellectually resilient it's to me that
when you go into a situation to be open
to the situation to the point that it
can scare you and that it can break your
plans and then to see that moment of
breaking as an opportunity to become
more than yourself
rather than shirking away from that or
trying to impose yourself on the
situation being open but being resilient
and so what we have done in um
these classes i'm not sure if i'm
allowed to reveal the course number but
maybe i am at c122 uh at uh at commander
general staff college is we have started
to implement this new uh creativity
training um and from there uh it
attracted interest from special
operations community and we have gone in
and done train the trainer and we've
also um initiated pilot programs with
the air force and the space force um and
we have supporters in the navy just out
of curiosity speaking from a
psychological perspective
um
do you and
i don't know how much research you're
doing while you're doing this but
obviously and this is something that is
a wide open field of investigation as
well i mean creativity is associated
with trait openness and resilience with
low trait neuroticism i mean
it is like would it be useful to
pre-select people on the basis of their
personality proclivity for creativity
training
it's hard because if you have someone
who's low in openness and that's often
characteristic of people in the military
because they tend to be more
conservative which means
higher in conscientiousness but lower in
openness
so
so you're totally right and this is
jonathan hayes work and other another
work and absolutely yes and this is true
each of us has our kind of own
individual boundedness we're not playing
slates where all of a sudden we can
become anybody we want to be and that's
completely correct what i just say to
people is we're here to maximize your
potential to be
creative
um and that's all we can do in this
situation and we're going to trust that
that's enough but i agree with you that
that the military could benefit from
from bringing on board um more creatives
the other thing is though is creativity
is not taught in schools
um i mean i mean i mean our our
educational infrastructure in this
country um is is not helping to access
so much of our human potential
it's hard to it's hard to grade
creativity that's part of the problem is
that creative people
because they're doing something new it's
very hard to lay an evaluation system on
them
so they're always breaking out of the
mold and and so it's very difficult to
build administrative structures around
that
it is but we think we've cracked that
problem well not about administrative
structures i should be honest with you i
mean one thing that you and i i think
have in common is i don't get too high
into um
structural reform you know i get very
nervous about but i'm all about
empowering individuals
and and and i just trust that the more
you empower individuals to be their
selves the more that the organic kind of
community will kind of grow up and
around that but yes absolutely we have
we have ways of of testing creativity
we're doing them in conjunction with um
antonio demacio's lab at the brainy
creativity institute my partner there is
professor john monterosso and basically
um what we do without going too deep
into the secret sauce um is we bring in
experts and ask them how confident are
you that this idea is going to work
so we don't ask them how creative it is
because we discover that you get a lot
of expert bias when you ask experts
about whether someone is creative
because experts will often decide well
if it's not something that uh that i
came up with or it doesn't fit my own
plans then it can't be creative or can't
work but if you ask them how uncertain
it is that it's gonna work it
immediately pushes them outside of their
expertise range and what we're starting
to identify there is therefore it must
be new because even an expert hasn't
seen something like that so if an expert
thinks it probably won't work but
they're still uncertain that's still
probably creative and if they think it
will work but they're uncertain that's
probably creative too and what we do is
we have panels of experts who come in we
can kind of systematize the process and
to answer your earlier question
it's all research that's why we're doing
this with the military is the military
is actively interested i would love to
do this research in the academy but the
academy is less interested in doing the
research than the military is and less
interested in the business community so
it's the business community and the
military that has opened their doors and
so even though yeah and you said yes
which is an interesting personality
characteristic
because i'm open and i'm right right
yeah no i have my openness is you're
probably uh uh deduced um
uh not always to my own benefit um
but it tends to fragment that's the
problem with openness right is you get
scattered
that is 100 my problem um but yeah so
i'm not getting paid i mean a lot of
people around me i mean a lot of people
who are using the the techniques that
i've developed are making a lot of money
off them but i haven't made any money
off them because i'm interested in doing
the research and and so that's why i
have kind of gone into all these spaces
and you know my hope overall is that i
believe deeply in um
i believe deeply in public service i
believe deeply in the ethos of the
military we can we can debate and have a
debate about whether or not we agree
with the ways in which the military is
applied and the uses to which it's put
and all those kinds of things but the
idea of having a group of people whose
job it is to put down their lives
to secure
our safety
seems fundamental to me well you already
made your moral stance clear about that
you said that your fundamental
supposition is that the best way to make
better societies is by concentrating on
making better individuals and so
hopefully you're contributing to that
and you know if someone criticizes you
you could always ask them well how are
they contributing to that exactly
so here's the thing jordan as i've
discovered in life uh
you can sound smarter faster by being
negative about someone else's idea than
by having your own idea so a lot of
people uh just like to kind of be smart
by attacking me um as opposed to coming
with their own ideas so i don't usually
ask them for their own because i assume
that they don't have them um but yeah no
i mean i i think to your point yes uh
the way forward for humanity i'm going
to ask you a weird question
so some of that money might be real
useful for you
you're a very creative person and you
said you know lots of people are making
money applying your ideas and so i think
well you know you had these ideas god
only knows what you might be able to do
if you had your position and some money
so
so this is this is uh something that's
um people have brought up with me before
they say angus they say if you had more
money you would have more power and if
you had more power you could do more of
the things you wanted to
and i actually and this is perhaps
erroneous and you might want to put me
on the couch and just abuse me of this
notion um i have the view that i'm
actually more existentially free by not
worrying about money at all because the
more you fixate on money at least in my
experience the more you end up doing
things you don't want to do and in my
life the more i've said no to money the
more i've been like this is really fun
and i'm enjoying myself and also i'm
empowering the people around me i should
also be honest ohio state pays me a ton
of money i mean i make a ton of money as
a professor um and i get
a lot of
invited up to give speeches for 50 grand
to pop you know um and you do a couple
of those a year i mean that's a really
good answer to that objection i'm i'm
thoroughly retracting my suggestion i
make enough money and you know there's
plenty of studies that show that if you
make more than you know 80 100 grand a
year you're not really substantially
more happy um i have had the experience
in my life to see a couple billionaires
up close
um and you know i won't deny that it
would be fun to be a billionaire for a
day you know and just be able to have
your own private island and your own
planes all those kinds of things but
very rapidly i mean one of them said to
me once pretty famously angus there's
only so many waterfalls you can see and
i think that goes down to the point that
ultimately
you know life is about
finding our self and we find ourself
through conflict and through struggle
and if you have money to remove all the
resistance from everything around you
it's actually much harder to grow
um and i don't mind the challenge and i
don't mind the difficulty and i don't
mind the friction and the fog of life
because to me that builds me up
and so i think a little bit of money is
good and necessary because you need a
safe space for yourself you need a
protected area where you can preserve
your sanity and kind of have kooky ideas
and whatnot um but if you have too much
money um
i mean you know this goes down to kind
of my general diagnosis of kind of
what's wrong with america at the moment
i mean i should say i'm an immigrant
people often don't know this about me
and so i have a very kind of quirky view
of america i chose to become an american
i was not born an american and so i
think like a lot of immigrants in
america i almost love america more than
most americans because you know i have
given myself to it you know um but i
mean i think the american dream in
america has kind of gone in these two
ultimately uninteresting directions one
is the idea that the american dream is
basically having much money
as you can get you know that's kind of
like the capitalist kind of conservative
side and then the other side is oh
america's here to provide me with
security
um and that's the kind of this kind of
like socialist kind of left-wing thing
whereas america's here to protect me and
america's not about that at all
america's about freedom
america is about freedom i came here and
i was more free
i've had more opportunity in america
than i would have had before
and that's not to say i have perfect
opportunity or everyone in america has
perfect opportunity or we can't get up
every day and give other people more
opportunities but that's the point of
america is to increase freedom to
increase opportunity not to make
yourself richer or to be safer um and if
you want to be more free a big part of
that comes from being free of fear
taking risks being free from yourself
being free from your own anxieties and
your own fears um and so a huge part of
what i just try and do every day is push
myself to where i'm lightly
uncomfortable
um and you know obviously i'm really
uncomfortable being on this on this
podcast because it's scary to be
honest about your thoughts when a lot of
people are listening
because you might say something dumb
or you might say something you regret um
but i want that because i want to get up
tomorrow morning and say you know what i
should have said this other thing or i
wish i hadn't said that other thing
because in terms of my
plan my path that will that will help me
and so that's one of the reasons i'm so
honored to be here honestly is because i
just don't have a chance to have very
frank open conversations like this as
much as i would like
yes it's a it's a it's a privilege
to have
that possibility manifest itself it's
been quite exciting for me to be able to
call people who i'm interested in and
say well you want to talk for an hour
and a half and they say yes and i think
well isn't that something i can ask them
all sorts of questions and i can learn
all sorts of things and i can share that
with like 500 000 people and like what a
deal that is i mean it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous yeah and that's the real
freedom because i think when people look
outside you know people sometimes look
at me and say oh you know money or
wealth or celebrity and i'm sure people
look at that same thing with you and
they say oh money celebrity isn't that
the really wonderful thing and it's
actually like no that's not the one it's
a chance to meet people it's the
removing of friction so so i can call
people and they take me seriously i mean
that's the real joy of my current
position you know that you can suddenly
start to just talk to almost anyone you
want and share those ideas and
experience that personal growth um and
that building of community yeah well
it's such a privilege too to be in a
position to be able to bring discussions
like this
for no cost to
like literally hundreds of thousands of
people you know it's it's an educator's
dream
so
this is a good place to stop angus you
know we've been going pretty hard for an
hour and a half and
i like
the way this just closed and
we covered a lot of territory
i would probably
like to talk to you again at some point
there's more things that we could
discuss i'm i have no doubt we'll see
how people respond to this and what else
they might want to hear about you got
anything else you want to
bring up mention or
no this has been perfect and i'm going
to go back and read some of the works
that you suggested um and if you want to
have me on again i would be honored and
excited to participate especially if
your audience would like to hear more of
us kind of um go back and forth yeah
with somebody that does that neumann
eric neumann he's a name worth knowing
he wrote the origins and history of
consciousness
and that's a great book it's a tough one
it's it's it's the
it's the it's the much deeper version of
a hero with a thousand faces and he also
wrote one called the great mother
which is an analysis of representations
of the feminine narrative
representations dramatic representations
of the feminine across history which is
also
a great book especially if you're
interested in neuroscience and instincts
because
the archetypes are tied to instincts in
a profound manner
and so it's a representations
imaginative representations of the
maternal across time that's the great
mother it's a great book i will read it
and then hopefully next time um i can
come back maybe things with special
operations will have an advanced a
little bit uh some of the work i'm doing
with anti-fragile ai maybe some of that
will advance a little bit great and we
can uh we can get into that
i'd love that all right thanks very much
it's a pleasure talking to you and uh
good luck with your work and your
writing and and you're educating all of
that and the work you're doing with the
military
thank you thank you
[Music]
you